[Music]
it's incredible I think you know a to be
able to meet her through his lens she's
an incredible woman that was making
Marco talking about the first time she
met the Queen and her future
grandmother-in-law
well this year marks the 65th
anniversary of elizabeth ii coordination
and now the English monarch is sharing
her memories from that crowning moment
there are some disadvantages to crowns
but but otherwise the cut important
things the queen and her very first TV
sit-down shows a rather quickie side
we've never seen the stage it's much
smaller isn't it the man chatting with
her is historian Alastair Bruce the
queen is never interviewed so we had the
film of the coronation and she and I
watched it together and made comments
and it was lovely to hear her
spontaneously remember like her color
commentary about this 1953 fairytale
spectacle her gold coach was led by
eight grey horses but her Majesty says
it was a bumpy ride horrible no need a
walking fish you know horses couldn't
possibly get any faster were you in it
for a long time halfway around London
her unprecedented TV appearance seems
like it fits in with the royal families
a recent trend of becoming more
relatable the Queen has been Queen for
66 years nearly and inevitably there are
huge changes and society constantly must
change the Smithsonian Channel special
the coronation also shows a close up
look at the priceless crown jewels the
Queen shows her cheeky side when looking
at the Imperial state crown you can look
down to read the speech you have to take
the speech up because if you did your
neck would break the Royal scepter is
topped by the star of Africa diamond at
530 carats as though largest cut diamond
in the world what really counts is that
the crown jurors are real they got the
story of their own they're not some
makeup Disneyland idea the leftovers
from the scepter diamond were turned
into the brooch the Queen wears in the
interview the top stone is 63 carats on
the bottom 94 carats it is
affectionately known as granny's chips
[Music]
you